now to the latest on the war in ukraine
kiev's forces claimed to have recaptured
snake island in the black sea and raised
the national flag russia says it
retaliated with missile strikes on the
outpost ukrainian president zielinski
today welcomed extra firepower of
weapons supplied by western allies in
the battle against russia but moscow
says it will step up its assault on the
eastern dawn bass region
the blue and yellow of ukraine flies
above snake island
once again it appears
this tiny strip of land became infamous
after the outbreak of the war
after ukrainian soldiers rejected an
ultimatum from a russian warship
the claimed recapture of the island
comes a week after russia withdrew
in what moscow called a goodwill gesture
but that goodwill did not last long
at about 5am several ukrainian
servicemen landed on the island and took
pictures with the flag
russian forces immediately launched a
strike as a result of which some of the
ukrainian soldiers were killed
snake island sits a long way from the
brunt of the fighting
still centered on the donbass to the
east
here russia's ground assault has slowed
its forces are regrouping after taking
less a chance
ahead of an unexpected assault on the
doniaz region
but they face a difficult road ahead as
ukrainian troops reinforced defensive
positions with western weapons
finally we can feel that the western
artillery the weapons we received from
our partners have started working very
effectively
their accuracy is exactly what is needed
our defenders inflict very noticeable
strikes on depots and other locations
that are important for the occupiers
logistics and this significantly reduces
the offensive potential of the russian
army
their losses will only increase every
week as will the difficulty of supplying
them
despite the brief pause in russia's
advance
missiles are still bombarding the key
cities of sloveyansk and kramer talks
for the civilians who remain here
the front lines are now creeping
dangerously close
w's nick spicer is in the ukrainian
capital and i asked him about the
capture and reported recapture of snake
island
it's pretty murky brent you know the
kremlin is communicating i think
symbolically here saying that they
killed some ukrainian soldiers while
they tried to plant the flag the
ukrainian defense ministry has provided
video of the planting of the flag
the kremlin has made all kinds of claims
before
rather implausible for example they took
out a whole
cadre of ukrainian generals and
commanders in one fell swoop and 10 of
those m777 american howitzers in the
same strike and we know they have some
targeting problems and so there is a
messaging from the kremlin which is
for a domestic audience that doesn't
necessarily correspond uh to the facts
on the ground and i think it's fair to
say that because there's no video
evidence provided and there's all kinds
of video about everything uh in in this
conflict but i think is really the
takeaway here is that the kremlin sees
snake island is something really
symbolic because as we heard in that
report it was where the soldiers held
out acted defiantly towards a russian
warship which was
the moskva the flagship of the russian
black sea fleet which was sunk
uh by ukrainian missile a little bit
later so there's a lot of well shame or
embarrassment around the snake island
story if you will and so the kremlin
seems to be coming back and trying to
sort of put a new spin on events and
nick we've heard ukrainian president
zielinski talking about the the positive
effect that western heavy weapons are
having is it clear though that these
weapons are making a big difference
you know again there's the fog of war
nobody is really providing exact details
about what weapons are deployed where
and which targets they are striking but
we know what weapons they
are being sent out into the field
particularly for american highmars
mobile rocket systems and just if you
look at the specifics of them those
missiles are accurate within one meter
with the ukrainians and the russians
have been firing at each other up until
now are accurate to within 500 meters
which explains the scorched earth
policies that the russians have been
pursuing to this point what it means
practically for the ukrainians and this
reflects what president zielenski was
saying in his statement is that if they
want to strike a weapons depot which is
what they what he's been saying they're
trying to do they can take out all of
the artillery shells or many of their
artillery shells uh that the russians
have been using in in their scorched
earth sort of you know rolling ways of
of uh artillery barrages strategy so it
is entirely plausible that they are
having an effect they're not having all
of the effect that the ukrainians would
like they're still asking for more
weapons we they're slow in getting
delivered but they appear to be making a
difference certainly if we go by what
the ukrainian president is saying
uw's nick spicer with the latest from
cube tonight nick thank you